au village sans prétention fait mauvaise
réputation
j'aime des mails ou que je reste coi je
passe pour un je ne sais quoi vous êtes
entouré d'une certaine légende de deux
côtés bougon de côté ronchon de yachts
et ça c'est le public vous a fait
quelque chose
il veut le voir sans doute un fondement
comment ça doit se baser sur quelque
chose je pense qu'à mes débuts
n'étant pas tellement destiné à passer
en public que j'ai eu des difficultés
quoi qui ont fait que en ce moment
j'avais un tract un peu après qu'un peu
un peu excessif jeunes fait pour tant de
tort à personne
en suivant mon chemin le petit bonhomme
mais les braves gens n'aiment pas que
l'on suive une autre route qu'eux non
les braves gens n'aiment pas que l'on
suive une autoroute créé
vous avez le trac comme ça c'est les
gens qui vous font fleurs enfin c'est
pas tellement le troc c'est une espèce
de une espèce de timidité de pudeur ça
me gêne un peu de me déshabiller devant
tout le monde
enfin quand vous avez terminé vos
chansons au lieu de saluer vous vous
tournez le dos messieurs je suis trop
gros pour s'élever ça nous met beaucoup
maigri d'ailleurs vous vous dire mais il
est contraint de tort à personne
en suivant les chemins qui mènent pas
l'arabe l'hébreu up l'on n'aime pas que
l'on suive une autoroute que non les
braves gens n'aiment pas que l'on suive
une autre route que vous avez peut-être
au fond de vous même une espèce de
réticences à l'exhibitionnisme que notre
métier quoi il ya peut-être ça aussi cru
si vous voulez bien sûr sans doute
y'a un enfant do